[Applause]
honestly from the bottom of my heart you
guys being here means the world just 11
weeks after his horrific crash
Kevin looked healthy and happy reuniting
with the rock in Cabo it's good to see
you brother no that's good to have you
guys good to be back it's been a
grueling recovery for Kevin who sat down
with me for Jumanji the next level his
first sit-down interview since the
accident all right yep first of all this
first time we've had a chance to sit
down how are you doing I'm good man
yeah better now that I see you my guy my
friend it's good to know that I got the
relationships that I have you know what
Tommy thank you man keV is feeling the
love but here's what's really next level
well let me say my thing first these two
heckling each other behind the scenes
did you love his Halloween costume
nailed it
I hated his Halloween costume Nelson
where he had my fanny pack he had to fit
everything
sorry
why are you dressed like that because
it's my costume all I gotta do is go to
the costume store say make me look
stupid I just didn't like the way he was
standing no I stood cooler I was like oh
[Music]